what is going on everybody welcome to
the second part of our Python and
programming for Finance tutorial series
in this part what we're going to be
talking about is actually building our
own algorithm on top of quanto peon but
of course in python mainly using the
zipline module we just so happen to be
using the quanto peon IDE in their web
app now in the last tutorial we showed
their version they gave us a sample
algorithm which worked on you know the 5
moving average moving over the current
price and in this tutorial we're going
to do a simple moving average crossover
so someone is some somewhat similar but
we're going to code it all line by line
ourselves so we can understand what's
all going on here but before we get into
that congratulations on making it to
these second tutorial that's actually
where we're going to lose the most
viewers so from part 1 - part 2 if you
made it this far you're already a winner
so congratulations
now what you're going to want to do is
make sure you're logged in to quanto
peon and then go ahead and click on
algorithms up here and what we're going
to go ahead and do is create a new
algorithm and I'm going to have this
algorithm we're going to call it SMA
crossover now a simple moving average if
you're not familiar with moving averages
go ahead and create create the algorithm
if you're not familiar with moving
averages what they are is basically you
take a window of days so we're going to
work with that first you know one price
a day basically so we're going to take
the past 20 days at every given point
and be like ok what was the average for
this you know 20 days and that would be
a 20 simple moving average so then we
can compare a 20 to like a 50 and when
the 20 crosses over the 50 that means
price is trending up and when the 20
crosses below the 50s that's when so if
20 crosses above the 50 I should really
stress that that means the price is
trending upward whereas if the 20
crosses below the 50 that signals that
the price is trending possibly downward
so when you create an algorithm you
should see kind of this you'll have
initialize and handle data now you're
going to have that every time because
these are just required bits of text or
like required methods rather now
because we're working with the quanto
peon web app these look a lot like
functions but don't don't let that this
fool you these are methods and they're
methods that belong to the trading
algorithm class of zip line so we're
able to do things with methods as if
these methods were contained within the
trading algorithm class so and instead
of self we're using context for the most
part and so just just understand that
because these are they're gonna they
look a lot like functions because
they're not being contained within a
class or so we think
but they are in the back end of quanto
peon so that can be kind of confusing so
try to wrap your head around that I'm
going to call them or at least I'm going
to try to call them methods but I'm sure
I'll screw up and call them functions
from time to time but they are methods
so you have initialized and handled data
methods these are required the
initialize method is going to run once
upon the starting up of the the class
basically when we create an object
although you know again because of the
web app we're not actually creating an
object or in the code but it's happening
and the so initialize will run in the
code that's under here will one once
upon the starting up and they have
handle data handle data is going to run
for each period so in our case we're
going to test on daily data so it's
going to run this code on every day of
data and that's the whole idea of a back
test right we're going to go day by day
through the history and see how we did
now what we are going to go ahead and do
is we're just going to call one thing
and initialize and we're going to modify
this context what context is is is a
Python dictionary if you're not familiar
with Python dictionaries I do have a
tutorial a basic tutorial on how they
work and how you can set new things and
reference parts of the dictionary so
check that out I'll link to it on this
window and if you're already familiar
cool so this is a Python dictionary and
it's basically how we track the state of
our of our trading right of our back
test where are we we define our
variables in here so wherever you might
think hey I should make a global
variable don't do it put it into the
context addiction
okay so first of all the first thing we
need to have is let's delete this pass
here and what we're going to put here is
context dot security and we're going to
say the context that security is equal
to the symbol for SP Y for the spy and
that is the spider s & p500 ETF okay so
it basically tracks the S&P 500 the S&P
500 is the top 500 companies or top 500
public companies by market cap so there
you go there's your initialize method
and now we have the handle data method
so what are we going to put in here
first of all let's um let's get rid of
this stuff here just delete that and
even the order CID stuff okay and then
within here we're gonna have a few
things first of all like I said I wanted
us to have a slow moving average and a
faster moving average so we're going to
have ma 1 and that will be this will be
our faster or yeah we'll make this the
quicker moving moving average so ma 1
will be a the equivalent of the data
that we're passing through now what's
data again because of the way this
quanto pian works in the backend
again this is a method and being passed
through data is the data that we're
getting on the security of the symbol of
spy they're doing a lot of things in the
backend I think to make it easier but
quanto being if you're watching I really
don't understand why you don't have the
classes there because it makes it
confusing especially if you don't know
Python already and you you're you don't
really understand and these look a lot
like functions anyway ma-1 equals data
and we're going to say data and again it
will be the data for what we're going to
say the context security so we're
referencing this up here and again if
these were functions we I mean we could
pass it through here but we're not
actually saying hey we never call
initialize here but the reason why we're
getting away with this is these are
classes and context is basically like
our self parameter okay so if you were
writing it you would actually insert a
context you'd probably use self dot
security and all of that anyway
Oh to reference we can reference what
the security is so like what are the
data that we want well we want the
context of security data so that would
be the spy data so we want that data and
this data here is simply pricing data
that's it there's nothing more to it it
comes out as a data frame so for example
we could we could print should come to
law will try printing it out and see
what it does at least but we should have
some data there so oops I'm not a string
print just straight up data as the
variable and we'll see what what we have
there and then ma-1 equals the data of
contact security and then we want to
apply a moving average so that's built
into quanto peein so you can do dat dot
and then you can just look at a list of
stuff that we can do here so we can
actually see all of the things that are
a part of this context security we've
got the close price date time the high
the low the open returns volume and then
voix is volume weighted AP volume rated
price I forget what the a is adjust
volume weighted adjusted price maybe I
don't know anyway so what we're looking
for is we actually want to apply the
moving average and then this only takes
one little property and that's how many
like windows do you want so over the
course of how many days do we want to
apply this and we're going to do over
the course of 50 days then we're going
to define ma 2 as the same thing
actually so let's just copy this paste
change this to 2 and change this to 200
and then now as we run this program we
want to be able to reference a few
different things within the program
really quickly so first of all we want
to know what the current price is at any
given time so we're going to say current
underscore price so to find this
variable is equal to data and then this
is going to be context dot security
security so data context our security
and then remember we can reference
elements of this data frame basically
and this will be the price column and if
you're not familiar with data frames and
pandas I have tutorials on pandas as
well I'll put a little link to them and
you can learn about those as well if
you'd like and then
it we're going to say we want to know
like what kind of positions are we in so
we'll say current positions those are
going to be equal to the context dot
portfolios portfolio dot and you can see
here see portfolio is also built into
quanto peon and this is where they track
automatically a bunch of stuff for you
capital use cash PL we can talk about
that later the portfolio value all this
stuff is just tracked automatically for
us so we can do all kinds of analysis
later on so we'll say portfolio dot but
we can track specifically positions and
then we want to track positions for what
we want to track positions for the
symbol of this spy and so when that
little window pops up you just just
click on it and that'll fill it in for
you and then we want to do dot and then
we want to know amount we want to know
how many do we have and then finally
let's just define one more thing before
we wrap this one up and we're going to
say we want to know cash how much money
do we have that's going to be equal to
context dot port folio dot cash and that
will tell us how much money we have at
the moment so then we can use these to
be like okay well how many stocks can we
buy at any one time well we take our
cash divided by the current price that's
how many we can buy right and how many
should we sell if we want to sell
everything
well we reference current positions
maybe or something like that so anyways
we'll cut it off here and in the next
tutorial we'll actually start building
the logic for our trading algorithm so
stay tuned for that if you have any
questions or comments over any of the
code up into this point if there is
literally anything you don't understand
here it can be anything if you're fuzzy
or whatever ask questions below and I
will help you figure it out and it might
be that you have to go through maybe
some basic tutorials to understand how
Python works but I also might be able to
have something directly to link you to
so ask questions below if you have them
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time